wollt ihr
Hello i Black
Koi z
wegen der Ende Mai an
Prozent deshalb löst werde
und noch unendlich viel mehr sehen auf
dem vierzehnten Splash Fastenal da an
macht bei uns mit und beantwortet eine
Frage
wie wir euch hier bei Facebook stellen
dann wollte er nämlich wenn er an zwei
Tickets die ab und die sind schon was
Wert
exklusiv der bei uns vergeben Alvin
Ailey gewinnen wollt dann werdet Fans
von Ecclestone auf der Facebook und wer
beantwortet folgende Frage
um wo findet das vierzehnte es der
Schwetzingerstadt
ich gebe einen kleinen Bars es ist die
Stadt aus Eisen und sie ist in der Nähe
von Berlin und dann könnte er zwei
Tickets gewinnen
um für das Festival das vom achten bis
zum 10 Juli also jetzt ganz bald dort
stattfindet ich drück die Daumen und
Prozent auf ein